I saw an Instagram there's this picture
of you and you're wearing a ring on your
left hand and everyone was like is she
engaged
is she not engaged can you just set the
record straight well I'm wearing a ring
on my left hand right now but as my
publicist Marcel will say when people
ask why is she wearing a ring on her
left finger he says because she has a
finger they're not an engagement ring no
I just the might the other day I was
eating I'd been eating too many salty
foods so it didn't fit up my it's my
emerald ring that I wear all the time my
right hand and I had to put on to my
left
because um my right hand was getting too
swollen I know that you're presenting at
the Oscars on Sunday what will you be
doing that morning I heard that we have
to do like last-minute changes to
outfits possible you have to kind of
keep yourself open for any dresses that
might come through but just kind of
being open and then getting glammed it's
gonna be all very chill and I hope very
then who your date is gonna be yet it's
gonna be Erin yes my boyfriend will come
with me